un bonsoir bienvenue dans le débat
politique du week end la gestion de la
crise sanitaire sous le feu des
critiques cette semaine trois ancien
ministre de la santé ont été auditionnés
cette semaine à lyon busin marisol
touraine où roselyne bachelot une
commission denquête devant l'assemblée
nationale qu'il heroes règlement de
comptes le patron de deux lits à chu de
marseille didier raoul qui a été traité
de menteur par le patron de l'ap-hp
martin hirsch accusations relayées par
le conseil scientifique et la haute
autorité de la santé et puis les
pompiers qui attisent les braises en
publiant aujourd'hui un rapport interne
incendiaires sans compter des plaintes
contre l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe qui ont été jugées recevables
devant la cour de justice de la
république
yat-il le feu à tous les étages c'est la
question de notre débat ce soir avec
patrick mennucci ancien député du parti
socialiste bonsoir avec nous également
florian philippot président des
patriotes bonsoir et merci à tous les
deux d'être sur rt france on va
commencer par ce rapport interne de la
fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers à destination du
ministère de l'intérieur qui n'était pas
destinée à être publiée voici un premier
extrait des nombreux dysfonctionnements
pointés regarder la décision du
gouvernement d'orienter vers le 15 les
appels des citoyens connaissant un doute
sur leur état de santé a eu pour
conséquence immédiate de saturer la
réception et la régulation des appels
des malades en situation d'urgence
vitale n'ont jamais eu de réponse et
sont morts dans l'indifférence générale
un vrai scandale voilà donc pour le
premier constat des vies sont en jeu
évidemment florian philippot premier
constat est ce qu'on aurait pu éviter
des morts là on le voit clairement en
tout cas là la saturation du 15 a laissé
des personnes sur le carreau
ça ça me paraît absolument évident on
sait que dans les ehpad il s'est passé
des choses absolument inhumaine
scandaleuse scandaleuse
on a vu le canard enchaîné avait sorti
une circulaire qui expliquait qu'il
fallait plus s'occuper d'eux en tout cas
fin mars début avril deux des personnes
âgées il fallait pas les emmener en
réanimation et c'est parce que on était
saturé et la basse le rapport choc des
pompiers je pense qu'il va dans la même
dans la même
logique c'est à dire une logique où en
fait on gère la pénurie et on gère la
pénurie au prix de vies humaines
voilà au prix de vies humaines mais le
problème c'est que on parle pas là des
objets on parle pas de marchandise on
parle pas non on parle de gens parlent
de gens avec derrière des familles avec
des enfants avec des frères des soeurs
des parents donc c'est à dire qu' il ya
des comptes à rendre sur cette affaire
des comptes à rendre non seulement dans
l'immédiat les personnes qui était
ministre de la santé au premier ministre
à cette époque là mais également si vous
voulez politiquement depuis des années
comment on a pu mettre à l'os à ce point
notre service public hospitalier
dans la cinquième ou sixième puissance
mondiale pour qu'on soit plus capable de
prendre en charge les personnes qui sont
qui nécessitent des soins à la première
épidémie venu
moi je trouve que c'est absolument
scandaleuse qui s'est passé scabreux et
il va falloir que les gens de rendre des
comptes
juridiquement mais aussi politiquement
alors c'est en cours il ya une
commission d'enquêté en ce moment à
l'assemblée
il y a également à ces poursuites
invraisemblablement devant la cour de
justice de la république patrick
mennucci est ce que c'est votre avis est
ce qu'on a fait tout ce qu'on a pu ou
est ce qu'on aurait pu faire mieux
c'est un peu difficile de après coup de
penser qu' on a on explique ce qu'il
fallait faire avec beaucoup de goût avec
beaucoup de conviction or la situation
était totalement exceptionnel ça
n'enlève que font rire bibeau a raison
il y a eu des dysfonctionnements massifs
le rapport des pompiers extrêmement
inquiétant il n'est pas terminé mais moi
je connais la fédération nationale des
sapeurs pompiers
c'est une structure qui n'est pas que
syndical il ya un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont des techniciens qui
travaillent pour les dix et qui cherche
à améliorer
non pas la condition des pompiers même
si il le faut on met les process
d'intervention est vraiment réfléchi je
pense à quai qui est en jeu un patrick
mennucci puisque c'est un rapport qui
n'était pas destinée à être rendue
publique et il d'autant plus crédible
oui moi je vais vous donner cette
fédération je connais un certain nombre
de nos fils y ait deux pompiers qui
travaille je les connais pour être déjà
extrêmement sérieux et connaissant
parfaitement leur métier donc je crois
que si ils affirment qu' il y a il n'y a
pas une utilisation maximum de ce qu
aurait pu être l'utilisation des
pompiers alors que d'autres structures
étaient était totalement débordés je
pense que c'est une vraie question sur
laquelle il faut qu'on se pose mais pour
répondre à votre question est ce que moi
je peux difficulté à mairie j'ai comme
juge
je pense qu'il y a des choses qui vont
se passer on a une commission d enquête
au sénat à l'assemblée nationale il y
avoue l'avait dit la cour de justice de
la république qui a accepté d'instruire
et non pas d' aujourd'hui de juger nous
sommes dans une phase d'instruction
certain nombre de ministres il y a des
des enquêtes il y a des rapports comme
celui que dont nous parlons est pour
avoir été rapporteur d'une commission
denquête à l'assemblée nationale et
d'ailleurs avec le même président de
celui qui préside la condition actuelle
eric ciotti je peux vous plier en effet
commission denquête sont sérieuses et
d'ailleurs on le voit concrètement à
quoi sert-elle concrètement et ça sert
qu à l'issue de la commission d'abord il
ya une diversité les parlementaires tous
les groupes politiques sont représentés
j'ai moins confiance dans la commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale qui a
déjà montré ses limites parce que tu es
en marche se sent acculé
mais ils liquident la commission
denquête comme ils l'ont déjà fait mais
au sénat ça ne sera pas possible et une
commission 24 rapport et ce rapport est
généralement regarder avec beaucoup
d'attention par les observateurs et peut
d'ailleurs aussi faire un certain nombre
de préconisations comme nous avions fait
avec eric ciotti compte un maintien de
terrorisme au bout beaucoup de ce que
nous avions proposé dans ce rapport et
aujourd'hui dans la législation couronne
dans la république soeur terroristes et
la radicalisation on vous entend donc
c'est fait pour améliorer les choses pas
forcément pour sanctionner des personnes
un florian sur place voilà un sujet moi
c'est bah c'est pas l'assemblée
nationale
j'aurais bien sûr c'est jusqu'à jeudi il
faut parler de cette géopolitique est ce
que ces 11 11
est-ce qu'il faut des responsables
florian philippot selon vous est ce
qu'il faut au même titre que l'est le
sang contaminé traduire les responsables
devant la justice
ça si vous voulez cesser aux familles et
aux personnes et aux proches des
victimes et aux familles des victimes et
aux victimes elles mêmes de le
déterminer elles génèrent personne est
au dessus des lois donc il peut
évidemment qu'il peut y avoir des
actions en justice
il y en a alors certaines se font devant
les tribunaux de droit commun et
d'autres devant la cour de justice de la
république parce qu'il s'agit de
ministre ça c'est ça c'est la loi mais
si vous voulez moi je pense aussi qu'il
faut une responsabilité politique parce
que ça fait quand même des années que
vous avez des soignants qui manifestent
dans la rue qui tire la sonnette
d'alarmé encore encore quelques semaines
avant la crise du coin d'un virus 1 et
qu'on a très mal traités on leur a
envoyé la troupe et qui disait on n'a
plus les moyens à l'hôpital public on
est sous on est orné alors voilà il ya
l'austérité qui s'applique
on sait que la commission open depuis
2011 à 63 reprises a demandé à la france
de baisser ses dépenses de santé le
calcul a été fait donc si vous voulez il
ya l'école des gens qui savaient on
savait qu'on n'était pas prêts on savait
qu'on avait fait à peu près n'importe
quoi pour les masques depuis on va dire
2011 2013 quand il ya eu le changement
de doctrine par la commission des
requêtes est en train de faire là la
lumière là dessus donc à la fois
pourquoi pas des responsabilités
juridiques parce que personne n'est au
dessus des lois et de la justice
mais en même temps et surtout j'ai envie
de dire il faut une vraie rupture
politique on peut pas continuer de
considérer que la santé l'hôpital public
c'est une variable d'ajustement
budgétaire comme une autre comme ça a
été le cas depuis beaucoup trop
longtemps parce que ça nous mène à des
drames il ya d'autres questions qui se
pose à moi j'ai vu madame juin devant la
commission denquête je trouve que quand
on apprend que alors que soi-disant elle
savait tout depuis le mois de décembre
c'est un peu ce qu'elle a dit luca s'est
baladé sur twitter en décembre à la vu
qu'il y avait quelque chose de très
inquiétant chine a prévenu tout le monde
très bien c'est bien elle dit qu'elle
est le seul problème c'est pas cohérent
parce que le 30 janvier elle commande
1,1 million de masques ffp2 vous savez
combien ça
combien de temps on dit on combien de
temps on peut durer avec 1,1 millions et
un milliard il en fallait un milliard
effectivement bien sûr on tient à peu
près deux heures on tient deux heures au
niveau national avec 1,1 million de
masques en pleine épidémie
allez donc cette commande n'a pas de
sens et là je trouve que la commission
denquête n'a pas suffisamment cuisine et
madame busin il fallu poser des
questions il fallait revenir à la charge
parce que c'est quand même une amie si
bon pas se contenter d'une vague réponse
alors là beaucoup cherché dans ses
dossiers elle a bon voilà elle avait
l'air un peu perdu mais il faut quand
même lui demander là des comptes s'ils
voulaient des comptes très sérieux on
est parent on parle pas dans le vide on
parle de derrière il ya des vies
d'aléria des vies humaines
il ya des conséquences pratiques elle a
dit effectivement que les commandes
n'était pas lié directement à sa
décision que c'était aussi les ars qui
étaient impliqués alors chacun seront
bien le ministre les ministres changent
si vous le dis juste valeur et contrôlez
pas si le défaut c'est comme ça chacun
se renvoie la balle on l'a vu on a aussi
vu roselyne bachelot devant la
commission devant l'assemblée cette
semaine et vous parliez des soignants
qui avait tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
voilà ce qu'elle leur a répondu en garde
et j'ai entendu un représentant d'un
syndicat de médecins dire nous n'avions
pas de masque dans nos cabinets m'enfin
des médecins qui n'ont pas de masque
dans leurs cabinets qui se constitue pas
un stock
nous n'avions pas de blouse m'enfin on
attend que le préfet ou le directeur de
la rs viennent avec une petite charrette
porter des masques
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce pays
infantiliser il faut quand même un peu
se prendre en main de ce pays c'est sa
valse on qu'il faut tirer tant qu'on
donc on a 30 doit tout qu'on attendra
tous du seigneur du château
on est mal voilà pour la réaction de
roselyne bachelot
patrick mennucci compenser vous il ya eu
beaucoup de réactions négatives de
médecins derrière moi je ne sais pas je
j'avoue que capte 91 ans madame à chaud
dont on peut reconnaître qu'elle a été
mise en cause dans le passé pour des
choses qu'elle ne méritait pas et c'est
vrai que notamment sur la question des
stocks de grippe des stocks de vaccins
deux nuls c'est vrai qu'on peut se
demander pourquoi les médecins n'ont pas
des masques dans leur cas mais c'est une
vraie question
là la doctrine sur les masques qui a
évolué faisait que par ailleurs les
entreprises devaient stockés des masques
la vérité c'est qu'il ya une circulaire
mais que personne ne la lui ai donc
l'art n'est vraiment je crois dans la
responsabilité de l'état c'est à dire
que quand madame busin dit c'est pas moi
c'est santé france qui doit tomber les
masques
c'est vrai qu'à ce moment là on peut se
demander comment fonctionne notre
république et à quoi servent les
ministres notamment m'amuser ne pouvait
pas ignorer parce que l'histoire
française est ainsi notamment avec les
pros c'est qu'il ya eu sur le sang
contaminé que le ministre de la santé
est particulièrement exposée et qui doit
être particulièrement attentifs et le
faire confiance au fond qu'à sa propre
conscience
même en étant évidemment entouré de
fonctionnaires de directeur cabinet de
conseiller mais in fine et c'est au
ministre de la santé de faire attention
ça fait je veux dire elle est pas prise
en défaut d'information en abuser parce
qu'elle connaît l'histoire de ce pays et
l'histoire des ministères de la santé
moi j'avoue que je suis stupéfait de la
semaine de la discussion ne veux pas
paraître d'interrogatoire en commission
des lois de l'assemblée nationale où
j'ai eu l'impression à un moment que
eric ciotti et plusieurs parlementaires
se sont retenus parce qu'ils avaient le
sentiment que madame buzet allait
craquer qu'elle n'était pas en capacité
de s'expliquer j'ai eu le sentiment
qu'ils récusent
une espèce de réaction d'élégance par
rapport à la ministre de la santé ne
voulant pas la pousser dans ses
retranchements
ça sera certainement pas l'attitude de
même si ça devait venir de la cour de
justice de la république qui ne
fonctionnent pas de la même façon
c'est vrai que là on a un gouvernement
qui le ce point de vue est à la dérive
dans les explications alors on peut
aussi dire parce que je moi je ne veux
pas être ou noir dans cette affaire-là
que c'est absolument exceptionnel ce qui
s'est passé bien sûr nous le savons que
ea mais il ya quand même la
responsabilité politique nerfs du point
de vue de femme disait si ce n'est de la
république en marche
la solution politique est venue à paris
elle était candidate dans va ptet pas
entrer trop dans les détails patrick
mennucci reconnaît avoir eu vent des
arts c'est le seul moment on a vu le
résultat j'aurais qu'on écoute à présent
cette passe d'armes puisque il ya
beaucoup de deux règlements de compte en
tout cas dans cette assemblée eric
raoult n'a été le professeur out a été
entendu au signal
le patron de liège suis de marseille il
a été traité de menteur par le patron de
la ph fait écouter cette passe d'armé on
en parle après la mortalité dans les
réanimations ici dans ce travail
toujours et de 43% chez nous elle est de
16%
ces déclarations qui mettent gravement
en cause de l'ap-hp faites sous serment
me semble s'apparenter un faux
témoignage
on a même fait un article malicieux en
en regardant les gens qui s'est exprimé
dans la presse pour ou contre la
chloroquine et on a match et ça avec le
nombre d'argent qu'ils avaient reçu de
de guilers et c'est parfaitement match
et voilà c'est le conseil scientifique
un qui est dans la ligne de mire du
professeur raoul tu florian philippot ça
en dit long quand même un peu importe
qui a raison qui a tort mais justement
sur les dissensions en interne sur les
scientifiques ne sont pas d'accord et au
milieu de ça il ya des français qui
risquent leur vie quand même non mais
moi je trouve ça lamentable le procès
qui est fait s'ils voulaient à didier
rahout façon on voit bien qu'ils veulent
sa peau en fait ils veulent sa peau
parce que quand il est venu devant la
commission denquête la fin juin il a il
a dit la vérité s'il a mis les pieds
dans le plat le vrai sujet dans cette
affaire ce qui s'étale sous nos yeux
c'est le problème des conflits
d'intérêts confie l'intérêt que des
laboratoires avril la cité gilles ead
moi j'ai lu une enquête de science et
avenir qui est sorti depuis qui dit
effectivement parmi les infectiologues
français largement le laboratoire en
tête dans les liens d'intérêts ce qu'ils
sont pas forcément des conflits
d'intérêts bruit parmi les liens
d'intérêts cgil ead est donc s'il est là
il a posé un vrai problème
donc au lieu de cibler d'enquêté sur le
fond parce que ça à vrai sujet faisons
la transparence gala qui sont justes
dans les liens d'intérêts il y en a qui
sont dans le conflit d'intérêts c'est un
problème c'est vrai que pour l'instant
rien n'est prouvé en même s'il a raison
sur le taux de mortalité apparemment
dans réanimation ben ça saoule et les
liens d'intérêts c'est pas prouvée ou
passe maintenant c'est obligatoire vous
devez vous devez les déclarer il ya
ainsi transparence pour un sante.gouv.fr
liste des médecins que vous avez leurs
liens d'intérêts
on sait que c'est l'iliade a alors après
si vous voulez ça c'est un vrai sujet
c'est un vrai sujet parce que c'est ce
que les médecins conseils du pouvoir
sont libres quand il où est ce qui
parfois ils pensent être libre mais en
fait ils ne le sont pas parce que parce
que pour plein de raisons et c'est pas
forcément qu'ils sont malhonnêtes mais
il se trouve qu'ils sont dans un système
où ils sont pris dans deux voilà dans un
engrenage mois en fait lors leur avis
n'est plus objectif
l'objectivité nécessaire donc un faux
procès lui est fait sur le fond parce
que l'auto manifestement le taux de
mortalité en réanimation en ile de
france c'est bien
environ 40% ça a été confirmé depuis à
bord du coupé sort comme ça et et
profits c'est ça a été confirmé par la
professeure lacombe
donc il n'avait pas tort donc le doc
martens il se plante pour le coup il se
plante il lui fait un faux procès le
taux à marseille je ne connais pas mais
en tout cas à paris c'est bien
malheureusement plus de 40 % et est sur
le fond il faut parler de ce que dit
raout il faut ouvrir le débat des
conflits intérêts des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques de gilet avec son rêve
zi vire dans cette affaire tout en
confirmant à la chloroquine leur ndlr
qui a été autorisé contrairement à la
chloroquine oui juste pour les uns vers
kasri réalisée par l'agencé européenne
du médicament la très récemment sais pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs parce que c'est
inefficace et gillet a annoncé un prix à
2860 dollar
franchement c'était dix ans et un prix
adapté aux pays riches ils en ont les
moyens c'est quand même c'est quand même
fort de café je pense que ça leur
revient à 5 mois ci de là ça pose des
questions patrick mennucci ce cette
collusion justement de ce conseil
scientifique qui conseille l'exécutif et
qui a des liens ils le disent eux-mêmes
ce n'est pas interdit
avec les grands laboratoires faut-il y
mettre un terme
finalement la réponse à votre question
pour moi est oui si les les très jeunes
scientifiques qui composent ces conseils
ne sort pas suffisamment payés il faut
réfléchir et peut-être les payer plus
part avec de l'argent de l'état mais je
trouve qu'il est vraiment mauvais que
des personnalités qui sont amenés à
donner leur avis à l'exécutif au moment
un moment aussi décisif de celui que
nous avons vécu à partir du début du
mois de mars
effectivement puisse être soupçonné
alors moi je ne sais pas du tout si
c'est vrai je n'ai pas les spécialistes
de ces questions
ce que je sais c'est que
le virus ne s'est pas développé de la
même façon en france selon les
territoires
et si vous prenez le département des
landes où le département du val d'oise
vous n'avez pas du tout eu les mêmes les
même emballement
donc est-ce que des calculs de
pourcentage en quelle j'ignore
totalement qui a raison dans cette
question j'ai entendu martine j'ai
entendu d'autres infectiologues qui
n'ont pas les mêmes responsabilités que
martin lemay qui sont en situation dans
les hôpitaux de paris s'est élevé contre
les propos de didier rahout et en même
temps j'ai mois plus tôt beaucoup de
considération pour didier out je vais
vous dire une chose eux normalement ne
dit pas à la télévision mais ma tante a
été soignée allié à chu de marseille par
didier raoult telles scènes et sorties
alors qu'elle avait 90 1 et croyez moi
je lui en suis extrêmement
reconnaissante
évidemment de l'avoir fait mais est ce
que cela veut dire que leur as raison
l'autre à tort moi j'ai beaucoup de
difficulté à le dire ce que j'aimerais
et là je le dis vraiment eric ciotti
puis à ceux qui vont présider commission
au sénat
c'est que on le parlement arrive à
sortir une vérité si ce n'est la vérité
mais que osama proche parce qu'il ya
quand même quelque chose de délétère
dans ce débat entre des grands
scientifiques qui sommes tous ceux
considérés comme des gens de valeur du
point de vue de l'infectiologie je
trouve que c'est très gênant pour les
phrasés d'avoir à se poser ce type de
questions et surtout que ça remet en
cause beaucoup de leur crédibilité merci
à tous les deux c'est là c'est la fin de
ce débat
merci d'avoir participé à ce débat sur
arte france merci à vous de votre
fidélité
restez avec nous